DETROIT.
THE MONTREAL CANADIENS, A
THRILLININ AGAIN, BACKHAND
WIDE EVANS.
PLAY WHEN IT'S DONE.ING
>> USUALLY IT'S GALLAGHER THE
GUY RIGHT IN FRO FLORIDA PANTHES
WITH IT.AT RECENTLY.
SHOVELS IT TO THE LINE. LINE CH.
TYLER ENNIS
SCHUENEMAN PUMPS ITHT AT THES OM
PITLICK AND SHOT IN BY OTTAWA.L.
>> Bryan: OTTAWA CHANCE ON THE D
ESTABLISHES THE STICK.
BACK TO
STANDS.
BARRON RIPS IT, AND HOW ABOUT
THE PATIENCE?
THE PUCK KICKED OUTL WAIT FOR O,
JOSEPH COULDN'T COLLECT.
KNOCKED DOWN B TERRIBLE PASS FRM
BRADY TKACHUK, JOE
SENTOUCHED
THAT.
YOU JUST WONDER WHY IS THIS ONE
GOING IN?
ANOTHER POWER PLAY GOAL.
THEY STRIKE 29 SECONDS I
FIRST TIP, SECOND TIP, AND I
THINK THAT SHOULD BE BATHERSON'S
FIRSIVE.
CONNOR BROWN TRIED TO GIVE
OT A SNIPES.
OTTAWA LEADS BY TWO.RT THE
MOMENT IS SHOOTS INTO
THE GLOVE AS BATHERSON WORKINGG,
UGH.
YOU SEE THE FOOT POP OUT